hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the
meditations as well as in other works
you're going to see Rene Descartes
making almost constant use of two terms
that play an incredibly important role
within his epistemology and his
reconstruction of the possibility of
knowledge those two terms are clear and
distinct or clarity and distinction and
he sometimes uses synonyms for these as
well if you're reading between the lines
so to speak you'll see many more
references and uses of these than simply
those two terms in meditation - we're
going to see it already being used quite
a bit and being invoked as an important
way of making sense out of our thoughts
and that a little bit later in
meditation 3 Descartes will actually
give us a rule that he's going to use
throughout the rest of the meditations
that anything that I conceive of clearly
and distinctly I can hold to be true he
doesn't quite have that working
explicitly in meditation - but he's
already making use of something like
and there's a lot of different ways in
which this comes up you know we can have
the general formula of conceiving ideas
clearly and distinctly what is it that
we're doing we're conceiving or thinking
or understanding or perceiving all of
these are modes of grasping something
and then what are we grasping in general
these can be called ideas or notions
right there are things that are present
to the mind and clarity and distinction
then are certain qualities or attributes
of those particular ideas or the way in
which we are grasping those ideas so
what is it then for things to be clear
and distinct this is something that
Descartes spends very little time
actually explaining he never provides a
formulation of precisely what it is for
an idea to be clear in the meditations
nor as a matter of fact in his discourse
on method instead he it's going to be in
his principles of philosophy that will
find this formulation of the idea being
present and accessible to the mind when
the mind is actually attending to it so
you know the opposite of clear is
obscure and a clear notion is something
which impresses itself upon us it has a
certain you could say self evidence in
how it is given to us so that we can say
ah yes I do in fact grasp what this
thing is so putting that aside saying
that we do understand what clarity is
because Descartes assumes that we we
really do have some sort of conception
of this we can say what's clear and
what's not clear what about distinction
this is a little bit easier to say
because Descartes is who's upon here
very clear about what it means to be the
state and for ideas to be distinct means
that there
not confused with other ideas we're able
to separate them out and see how they're
different from each other so Descartes
will use this language really throughout
meditation too and we can see a number
of different examples of this some of
which I want to focus on and one of the
most interesting ones is his famous
realization that if I am being deceived
if I am having any sort of thought
whatsoever then I must be able to say I
am I exist and this is often framed in
terms of what we call the coachee toe I
think therefore I exist this is
something that Descartes takes to be
completely clear and we can also say
that it's distinct from other
formulations other realizations the fact
of my own existence my knowledge or
notion of my existence is something
different from my notion of other things
existing and so this is something that
qualifies as very clear and distinct but
he talks about a lot of other things as
well as having a certain kind of clarity
and distinction for example a little bit
after that when he is talking about the
notion of body and he says that it has
all of these different characteristics
these are things that I can distinguish
apart from each other for example being
able to be in a space and exclude other
things from the space being able to be
seen heard sensed in other ways having a
certain extension or a figure whatever
we want to call it
all of those are distinct from each
other and those are also clear within
the conception of a body or a corporeal
thing or extended thing so he goes on
and he let's come back to the I am I
just the thinking thing he says that if
I think about what it means to be a
thinking thing a thing that thinks what
is that he says it's a thing that doubts
that conceives that affirms that denies
that wills that wills against that
imagines also and which senses or
perceives through senses and he says all
of these are distinct from each other
all of these are modes of thought that
we can distinguish and he knows clearly
or he has a clear conception of the fact
that he is doing those sorts of things
there's another passage a little bit
later he says it is of itself so evident
so clear we might say that it is me who
doubts who understands and who desires
that there is no need of anything else
to add in order to explain it so that's
another great example of something
that's a very clear set of ideas I know
that I am the one who desires I am the
one who senses I am the one who
understands and he says and it's also
certainly the power of imagining right
for just as it happens that that I
imagine the things the things that I
imagined are not true nevertheless this
power of imagining does not leave or it
is not a lack you could say any any
reality in me and and it's part of my
thought the things that I imagine I can
imagine in some cases at least quite
clearly and I know clearly that I have a
power of imagination so all of these are
presenting themselves with a sort of
self evidence you could say all of the
different modes of thought that are part
of the Cartesian coach ito that's
something we can be quite clear about
what about other things we can be clear
about the general notion of what
includes right the ideas of bodily
external things in general although he
says you know at some point sometimes
general notions are kind of confused
right and that would be the opposite of
being distinct but he says well if we
take individual things and here you
might think of the famous example of the
piece of wax or of other things that he
says could be equally applicable any
other physical thing including the
people outside of my window who I think
our people even though they could just
be machines or things like that insofar
as we're thinking about the thing in
terms of its substance that turns out to
be something that is quite clear and he
also goes on and he tells us that you
know when it comes to the sensations
that we have of it those sorts of things
are also clear and distinct ideas not
clear and distinct ideas in the sense
that they automatically tell us that the
thing that they're attached to or
signifying or whatever we want to say
they're representing it does actually
exist could be that no corporeal objects
actually do exist at this point but the
ideas that we have of them are at least
clear and distinct right he goes on and
he he says that if we carry out this
process of stripping away all these
sensible qualities and we think about
the piece of Wax
says the notion and knowledge of the wax
seems to be more clear more in that case
next in French and more distinct after
it has been discovered not only by sight
or touch but also by many other causes
with so much evidence such distinction
and clearness that I myself you know
understanding myself
can be compared to that
so our ideas already in meditation - can
indeed have this this quality qualities
of clarity and distinction
it doesn't mean yet at this point in the
game that they automatically are true in
the sense of referring to the reality of
the thing that they seem to signify if
we're talking about external things if
we're talking about things that pertain
to my own self and my own thinking well
then the clarity and distinction that we
have which dhikr takes to come in part
from what he calls the natural light we
attend to ideas and there's a sort of
natural light that illuminates them it
means that we can't be wrong about those
so this this criterion of clear and
distinct ideas is going to play an
absolutely central role in the entire
argument of the meditations and you can
see it playing an important role already
though less explicitly drawn out in the
things that Descartes is particularly
concerned with in meditation - which are
the human mind and its various types of
thoughts physical objects hopefully
outside of the mind though though we
don't know that yet and the apprehension
that we have of those objects both
through how they present themselves to
the senses and even more importantly how
the mind or understanding grasps them
you